you see I think George Lucas should take
notes from Nintendo if you're gonna re
release something and re-release it in
3d make sure you do your best work first
if you're gonna change anything changing
for the better
pretty good recipe for success but I
think all right so this is the second
3ds game I'm gonna review for you guys
and ironically it's the second game
that's also a rehash of an old Nintendo
64 games we're good games though starfox
64 3ds exactly what it sounds like it's
Star Fox 64 re-released on the 3ds in 3d
and of all the 3d gimmicks out there the
3ds is one that it just doesn't bother
me I don't know if it's because if you
pick the thing up you know you're
getting a 3d device or is because you
can turn the 3d off or it drops like a
hundred bucks recently in any case Star
Fox 64 3 D how is it it's a blast it's
just like the old Nintendo 64 version
you remember but all the graphics are
revamped just like Ocarina of Time was
it plays really smoothly like when you
have a game that relies on depth of
field and it's in 3d if the 3ds not
accurate it's gonna throw you off
entirely but this game the 3d I think is
accurate so when you're aiming for a guy
you're like I think I should aim there
yep I hit him because it's 3d that
actually works now I remember Star Fox
64 being like the pinnacle of hardcore
gamer game now it's not really like that
if I could describe this game in any way
shape or form I would call it a casual
game a casual game this really fun I
personally like casual games and by
casual game I mean like this is the
perfect kind of game to have in your 3ds
in your pocket you're waiting in line
for like a movie or something like that
just like a half an hour to kill what to
do oh I brought my 3ds with my Star Fox
64 3 D let me beat a level it is close
it it'll go to sleep you pick it up when
you need to kill more time that's what I
like about portable games they're just
good time killers starfox 64 in this day
and age is a perfect portable game but
you can blow through this game in like
20 minutes maybe a half an hour like Max
and when you're done you're like oh that
was easy but you notice there are
different paths you can take throughout
the galaxy like if you beat a certain
level a certain way if you take a
certain exit you'll go on the hard path
now and that path is well harder it's
just because you blow through the
single-player campaign once doesn't mean
you've maxed out the game try different
paths it'll help you feel like you got
your money's worth now just like the
Nintendo 64 original every level has
like three metals you can get and
getting them on here just like the
Nintendo 64 is a pain in the ass it is
and I'll admit I haven't done it I
haven't gotten a gold medal on every
level I remember back in the day and
then Nintendo 64 my brother did I don't
know why he's a freak like that he's an
alien or something but he got a gold
medal on every level me you've gotten it
on like you know couple because I sucked
like that I'm not a freak robot sent
from the fee
to max out every level on Star Fox 64
cuz I have like perfect reflexes and I'm
not my brother so it'll take me some
time trying to get a medal on every
level that's hard ass to do that's
where you really get your long-term
money's worth and even get into certain
levels it sounds simple it's like a flip
all these little switches on the track
that's easy right no it's not it's
annoying as hell because that little
tank is annoying to drive there's only a
couple levels in the game that use that
little tank that you get the little Land
Rover so I'd say those are the hardest
levels right there luckily unlike the
Nintendo 64 version I don't remember the
Nintendo 64 having this mode you can
just go into the options and pick a
level you've already been to and beaten
and you can just do that level right
there on the fly you don't have to like
go through the entire galaxy to get to
that level to try to get the metal so
that was cool because if I had to go
through 90% of the game to get the one
level to try to get a metal yeah after
losing that a couple times I'd probably
I'd and peppy still sounds like some
alcoholic yeah I just don't think I
should use the boost to get through an
asteroid field that sounds very
dangerous sir become more like your
father hippie are you drunk right now
did you have slippy blow into your
breathalyser Locke device on the
steering wheel of your Arwen you should
not be flying that thing right now yep
same old peppy as for the multiplayer I
didn't get to play the multiplayer much
because none of my friends have the game
yeah I'm the cheap one and none of them
have bought the game they all have 3ds
don't know but in order for me to really
play the multiplayer I'd have to go find
friends and then buy them 3d asses and
then buy them the game and then pay them
to be my friends that'll actually play
me it'll get expensive so the only
multiplayer I played was against the
computer but it was actually still fun
yeah the computers a douchebag when the
time starts counting down he really
start going after you doesn't change the
fact that the levels are really fun to
play I think they're more detailed than
they were in the Nintendo 64 I don't
remember them having that many obstacles
in it it could be wrong no it could be
just pulling that out of the air well
what are the levels is the asteroid
level you feel like you're in Star Wars
or something I feel like when the slave
one's going after obi-wan an attack of
the clones just bringing those lasers go
in everywhere I hate to use it in attack
of the clones reference I really do how
about this the asteroid scene in Empire
Strikes Back with more lasers there you
go in the end Star Fox 64 3 D the 3d
looks really good it has a really fun
single-player campaign it has a really
fun multiplayer even though I didn't get
to play it with human beings you'll blow
through the single-player campaign at
first and then trying to find all the
nooks and crannies and secrets that'll
take you some time and try to get all
the metals that will frustrate you and
take you more time so you get your
money's worth that way I'd actually say
pick it up is one of those games that
once it's in your 3ds you won't take it
out for a while because you'll realize
that when you go out and do stuff you
have a lot of down
time you have a lot of just waiting
around in a line for some odd reason so
you just pull out your 3ds beat a level
in starfox it's awesome I play it in
lines and so can you have you played it
what's your favorite game for the
Nintendo 3ds and actually what's your
favorite Nintendo 64 games cuz that's
probably gonna end up coming out for the
3ds and 3ds there's always that comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]